intitulé afghane world diaries ces
documents confidentiels démontre la
dissimulation des pertes aux civils
l'existence d'un escadron de la mort et
le double jeu du pakistan dans le
conflit des révélations suivi d'une
tempête médiatique
julian assange devient alors un homme à
abattre pour les états unis
les etats unis condamnent fermement la
publication d'informations
confidentielles par des personnes et des
organisations qui pourraient mettre en
péril la vie d'américains et dé nos
alliés et menacer notre sécurité
nationale
ces fuites irresponsables n'auront pas
de conséquence sur notre engagement en
cours des informations à l'origine
divulguée par bradley manning connue
aujourd'hui sous le nom de chelsea
manning analystes de l'armée américaine
au total plus de 91000 fichiers sont
diffusés et wikileaks ne s'arrête pas là
octobre 2010 le site public 400000
rapports confidentiels sur les guerres
d'irak et d'afghanistan ainsi que 250
milles télégrammes diplomatiques du
département d'état américain
là encore c'est bradley manning qui est
soupçonné d'avoir transmis les documents
la planète politique est en
effervescence
plusieurs pays sont mentionnés dont la
france
mais le 18 novembre 2010 la suède lancé
un mandat d'arrêt à l'encontre du
fondateur de wikileaks dans le cadre
d'une enquête préliminaire pour un crime
sexuels présumés sur deux suédoises
julian assange est dans le viseur de la
justice lui clame son innocence il
trouve refuge dans l'ambassade de
l'équateur à londres où il demande
l'asile politique le 19 juin 2012 pour
échapper à une extradition vers les
etats-unis une longue épreuve commence
pour le lanceur d' alerte
quelques années plus tard le 19 mai 2010
est alors qu'assange est toujours reclus
dans l'ambassade
la justice suédoise décide finalement
d'abandonner les poursuites avant de les
relancer en mai 2019 pour les abandonner
définitivement le 19 novembre faute de
preuves
beaucoup de temps s'est écoulé depuis
les faits avec pour conséquence
d'affaiblir les éléments de preuve au
point que j'ai décidé de classer
l'enquète sans suite
tous les actes d' enquêtes ont été
épuisés sans en apporter les preuves
requises pour une condamnation
un soulagement pour
julian assange malgré des conditions de
vie éprouvantes
aujourd'hui est une immense victoire non
seulement pour moi mais pour les droits
de l'homme dans leur ensemble durant
cinq ans j'ai été assigné à résidence
dans cette ambassade sans pouvoir voir
la lumière du jour pendant que mes
enfants grandissent et sans moi c'est
quelque chose que je ne pourrai jamais
pardonné ni oublier car j'ai subi une
immense injustice
alors qu'il était protégé par rafael
correa l'ex président équatorien lenin
moreno son successeur durci les
conditions de vie du lanceur d' alerte
le président équatorien n'a jamais caché
son désir de se débarrasser de celui
qu'il qualifie lui même comme un
problème hérité le 11 avril 2019
julian assange est extrait de
l'ambassade d'équateur par la police
britannique
avec l'aval des autorités équatoriennes
le fondateur de wikileaks est
aujourd'hui toujours en détention
préventive à la prison de haute sécurité
de belmarsh à londres dans la tente de
l'audience judiciaire sur la demande
d'extradition des etats-unis qui doit se
tenir à partir du 7 septembre prochain
depuis dans le monde entier les soutiens
de julian assange dont reporters sans
frontières et des associations de
défense des droits de l'homme organise
des rassemblements pour éveiller les
consciences et dénoncer ce qu'ils
considèrent être une atteinte à la
liberté d'expression
si l'extradition devait aboutir julian
assange risque 175 ans de prison pour
avoir publié des documents classifiés de
l'armée américaine dans lesquelles sont
exposés ceux qui s'apparentent à des
crimes de guerre et des crimes contre
l'humanité